hello everyone this is emily here from
audio science review
uh we're going back to school with a
technical topic
namely uh electrical grounding um
i'd say there's no more misunderstood
concept than electrical grounding
and even engineers get this wrong i can
tell you that
when i went to engineering school i
wasn't taught this and even when i
practiced this
engineering i wasn't taught this it's
something that
it's uh it can be explained very simply
but
uh your intuition gets you in trouble so
let's go through some of the myths that
people have
and the top one is really the what many
audiophiles think
and that is the fact that they think
that
uh you can take uh equipment noise and
drain it into the ground they have this
uh uh
you know common intuition that says you
know when i'm in a sink i
turn on the water and water drains into
some place and it goes away
therefore same thing must happen with
electricity and noise and of course
noise is not good and oh by the way i
fee
you know i hear the lower noise floor
blacker background but
you can't measure that so we'll go
through what's wrong with that argument
there's a color area color area of that
is that you can if if the ground is a
good thing maybe you should have a
dedicated
one for your audio system and if you're
going to have a dedicated
you know electrical circuit might as
well have a dedicated
one for your audio system as well
the third one is this notion of star
grounding this is
a real thing but people think all i've
got to do is star ground
all my equipment and i can never get
ground loops or hum and then this noise
can't happen
so they go plug everything into one
outlet or one shared ground and they
expect that to solve their problems
let me tell you that some of these are
illegal
you're not allowed to do them and
they're all
completely completely wrong and
i'm about to explain why
now instead of me explaining all these
things i highly encourage you to go
look for writings of bill whitlock he's
president of jensen transformers which
sells transformers for
creating balanced circuits but he has
one of the
best explanations of why these concepts
are wrong
this is a presentation that he has made
at audio engineering society
chapter and but he also has many other
papers many
many other online tutorials he teaches
classes
he's by far the expert in this thing
and he has a way of proving his points
that just
ironclad and the proofs are so simple
electrically and rely on such simple
physics that
good luck trying to argue with him uh
not because he's
you can't argue with them but it's just
you know you have to
think you know you have to argue that
the aliens exist
before you can prove them wrong so these
concepts that couldn't be more correct
but
misunderstood and not known so remember
this name bill with log he's been kind
enough to give permission here for
people to give his presentation the
actual presentation is about 100 pages
i'm not going to put you through that
uh just a handful of slides i'm going to
borrow from him because i'm too lazy to
draw the diagrams as written drawn the
most important concept that
everybody needs to understand is that
electrical circuits have to be completed
to become a circuit
so take a battery like this it's got a
positive
and a negative terminal if i hook up a
light bulb to the positive terminal will
the light come out
no the light bulb needs to be connected
to positive
and negative and when i do that then a
circuit will get completed
and i'll be able to light up the light
if i don't do that nothing happens if i
just hook up a wire to the positive
terminal like this
nothing will happen because the wire is
not going anywhere so current can't flow
and if current can't flow
the battery can't drain so it just sits
there does nothing
so this comes back this notion of you
know can you drain
noise uh into something with just one
wire
noise is a voltage source just like this
it's a signal
and it has to be completed it needs to
have the path
for it to do something so a single wire
transmission does not work unless you
want to build an antenna
but otherwise it just does not work as
as something that completes the circuit
i won't get into the rest of these for
now
um some of it is i've sort of
implicitly covered but so let me cover
the last bit of it if anybody ever
doubts you
and and you can't you know follow the uh
repeat the arguments that i've made just
tell them this ask them
how if you need grounding you know noise
needs to drain into the ground physical
soil in your home
uh how's it that airplanes have no
trouble
uh having extremely sensitive
electronics with no noise right they
have transmitters
and receivers avionics all that works
you can have audio systems
quiet how about in the car car doesn't
have a connection to the ground right
you don't drag a chain behind your car
to get quiet sound right so
know that noise is
you know it's not something that
requires earth to work
okay now the earth can cause the
grounding can cause problems
as i'll cover but just erase this notion
that
earth is a place where you store noise
that you dump noise
it's not how it works and i just gave
you two existence proofs of
how real life circuits work without that
dependency
to fully understand this topic you need
to understand how
our ac delivery systems work
unfortunately i don't have knowledge of
how they work overseas but i imagine the
concept is similar to what we have
in u.s you have a ac transmission is
high voltage
comes down at some point goes through a
transformer and steps down to
120 volts and and you get two of these
uh
uh coming in to uh to your residence in
u.s
at least modern wiring this can be rated
100 amps or 200 amps or whatever you
have
coming in in your service entrance that
large amount of current then gets
divided up in your breaker panel into
different branch circuits at the rated
amplifi amperages so
most common u.s is that these are 15 amp
and each one was protected
protected with a breaker so if it sees
more than 15 amps for a few seconds
it will trip or if the uh if it sees a
lot more than 15 amps it'll break a lot
sooner
so this wire is called the line or the
hot wire and it's black
comes in and it connects to one of the
pins in your outlet
then there's a second wire which is the
center tap of the uh this transformer
and that's called the neutral and the
neutral connects to the other pin
your equipment has hot and neutral going
into it when you plug it into this
outlet
and it then creates a circuit where
current flows from line goes into the
equipment goes through a neutral and
comes back
and completes this path over here so
things are constantly moving between
these two lines
there's a third wire that
comes from the same point that the
neutral
came and it goes to this center pin
like you have in these outlets you know
which is what i call safety ground
okay so you have a third pin in here and
that's the safety ground
that wires green by convention and
but it plays no role in what i just
explained
the only current that flows right now is
between line and neutral the ground
wires sitting there doing absolutely
nothing
and it's basically a redundant path to
the neutral wire because they both go to
the same place right
neutral goes in here ground goes in here
okay so remember that this ground path
did
nothing for you right now because all
this done is connected to a chassis of
your equipment
doing nothing okay now let's talk about
what the ground wire
is used for let's say this hot wire the
line wire inside your equipment
comes loose and it connects to the
chassis
of your equipment which usually is metal
right the moment it does that your whole
chassis is now energized
if you touch that if there was no other
protection mechanism you touch that you
get an electrical shock and and
you could die so very serious risk in
there
so to remove that risk or lower that
risk
we take the uh the chassis and hook it
up to the third pin
of this outlet and that becomes our
ground
and goes to the same spot now imagine
this has happened this hot wires come
loose
it's connected to the chassis the
chassis is a styled piece of metal so it
has
almost no resistance to current so now
we have basically a short circuit
hot wire comes in here immediately
connects to ground
circles back and goes through and
completes this circuit
with 100 amps on tap over here
this circuit now also goes from maximum
of 15 amps to
100 amps available to it and this
breaker here
boom it'll open up you know there's a
little bit of delay in there and
it will open up so as soon as this comes
loose connects to the chassis
boom this disconnects and the hot wire
is no longer hot
and therefore your chassis is no longer
hot and you're not going to get a short
you're not going to get electrocuted the
equipment doesn't work
because this concludes but you know we
have
triggered the uh breaker to come out so
the key is that now the ground wire
becomes
becomes completing the circuit in here
not the neutral wire
and that is why it's there it's a form
of redundancy and it's for safety
notice what bill has circled in here the
fact that this was hooked up
to the ground to dirt outside there was
this ground rod that went to the earth
outside
has absolutely nothing to do with this
path
right this path was here from the ground
going in here boom and the breaker broke
nothing went down to dirt why does it
not go to dirt
because remember there's no circuit in
here where would it go from here
there's no path for it to go it
electricity likes this path because it's
got the least impedance as we call it
and
it goes right here say hey i'm going to
complete this circuit why would i go
this way where is it
where to go after this this ground rod
is
is in here in case of a
lightning strike to the wiring that's
upstream of
of your this transformer on your feet
should that hit there there's a path in
here
that will bring it down to ground
because those poles also
are grounded so some of that energy gets
shunted down and i've covered
surge protectors and things later on but
that's the only thing this thing is
supposed to do
is deal with with these surges from uh
you know lightning strikes externally
coming in here
it plays this ground rod that's outside
of your home
plays no role either in normal operation
of your system
or in the event that this is shorted out
okay now let's talk about what the audio
file goes and does
he goes and and hires people and spends
good bit of money is not cheap
to put a stout ground rod in there or
maybe multiple
rods he goes research researchers uh
chemical you know bonding and grounding
and there are all kinds of
schemes in there and builds himself a
great ground for his audio system and
whether it's one outlet or more doesn't
matter so now his ground is connected to
this he
naturally disconnects the ground that
used to go to the main service panel
because that's the ground that he's
trying to replace with a
better one now let's follow what happens
when we have this same
short the hot wire comes in here
connects to the chassis
connects to the ground goes to the
ground wire
but it can't follow this path anymore
because that's disconnected where does
the electricity now go
to this new ground route that he is
installed
and it now wants to complete the circuit
so
what is the circuit that exists between
these two ground roads
right one is on this side of the house
the other one's on the other side of the
house maybe 50 feet away
you think dirt and vegetation and rocks
are great
conductors of electricity they are not
the impedance in here could be good 10
or 20 30
100 ohms i mean depends on how bad and
what the condition of your soil is
and because this impedance is high a lot
of that current can get lost in here
dissipated in here the power can be
dissipated in here
so as a result what carries through this
path now
can be low enough current that this
breaker will not trip
it will not see necessarily 15 or 20
amps to break it'll
stay conducting and if that stays
conductive means
the energized chassis of your equipment
that's now at 120 volts
continues to be at 120 volts you touch
that
you can die for this reason
the national electric code any seen u.s
does not allow you to have more than one
ground for a premise
from here on from this line on you
better have a single ground and this is
your ground
you cannot do this this is against the
code
against safety and there's no reason to
do it
it doesn't do anything for noise anyway
remember if there's noise in here and
you're connected in here what's it going
to do where's the circuit that it's
going to go to
there isn't any noise will not want to
follow this path
it is not a path that he likes to follow
because it doesn't go anywhere
okay so do not do not do not please do
not go do this unsafe things and waste
money
if you've done it you need to undo it
you need to disconnect this ground
and connect this you can go waste money
to make a better ground in here but
that's only good for lightning strikes
and what have you it has nothing to do
with the performance of your audiences
okay
now here's the tough part about this
no matter what you do you could have the
safest cleanest
installation best wiring in your home
and you can still have
hum and ground loops remember this
even in the safest best implementation
you can have ground loops
why can you have ground loops and they
say yeah i've got another slide
when you have multiple outlets in your
home
you can never assure that this these two
safety grounds are at the same voltage
potentials
so there's always some kind of voltage
differential between these outlets
and no matter what you do so keep that
in mind you cannot have
zero potential system and this gets a
little complicated to talk about
impedances and things like that but
there's no such thing
as zero impedance and zero voltage
indeed up to three volts
can be allowed and i've got a little
instrumentation special meter you can
get
it'll show you that you have a voltage
drop differential between these
these outlets so remember that even in a
fully code compliant premise
you can still have differential between
these
outlets so what does that mean that i
have this differential
we have two types of interconnects in
our audio equipment
we have rca or unbalanced
connections or we have balance or xlr
connections
what's the difference in an unbalanced
connection
remember we always need two wires to
complete the circle circuit
it unbounds that second wire
this is a signal wire coming out the
second wire is also the same as your
chassis
of that safety ground remember what was
hooked up to
that is also used as a reference for
these two so this output is reference to
this relative to this
with a differential or balanced output
sorry i shouldn't have said differential
as something else related but not
exact here the two signal wires
that are used to transmit have no
connection to the chassis
and and i'll show in a second when you
don't have that then it does not matter
what the voltage is difference is
between these two chassis whereas in
here
it does um
about so far i've been talking about
three pin uh
ac outlets but many devices come with
two pin and
uh the code allows that as long as
there's enough safety measures
in the equipment where that kind of
short that i showed does not
exist now you might think well okay if
that doesn't exist
the chassis therefore should be at zero
volts no
there's this thing called parasitic
capacitance there's a
way for electricity to still travel
from your ac wiring to the chassis and
energize it
you ever touched a laptop or some device
or shaver or something that's plugged in
and it gives you a little buzz
those are almost always a double
insulate that's a two-wire connection
why do you get that bust that's actually
a mild electrical shock
the code allows some amount of of
leakage or some amount of that that
voltage
can couple to the chassis but it limits
the amount of current in there
to a level that won't kill you it won't
hurt you but it does not guarantee that
it's zero
and because you know and when it's
elevated it can be high enough where you
feel that buzzing sensation when you
touch it and feels like a mild electric
shock
well the moment you have that and you
have this unbalanced rca connection
this voltage and this current can
actually now travel between these two
chassis
and it superimposes on top of your music
signal so your music signals playing
from the transmitted receiver
but you also have another one that is ac
and
all these harmonics traveling along with
it for the ride
those two get combined the receiver
doesn't know the difference it thinks
both of those
are your music so it plays your music
plus it plays a
hum on this thing now bill says
typically this is not a problem because
you know unless your interconnects are
long this is not the case
because of our long day-to-long
audio chains we have these days with
computers and then
external dacs and and then downstream
devices
you could build you could get in trouble
pretty quickly even with short wiring
and indeed many people
do you know they have short
interconnects or just a little
amplifier dac on their desktop that say
c mains powered and
they're hearing buzz and hump so just
know that this notion of using rca
unbalanced connection it's just faulty
to begin with
okay and that's what this talks about
that the tiniest amount of
flow in here doesn't need to be much can
cause
um this kind of uh
you know noise and hum and buzz that
gets communicated the proper way to do
it and what a
you know real audio interconnect should
have been years ago is this
uh balanced connection which is
typically driven also differentially and
i won't talk about what differential
means
but the key in here is that you can have
now
current flowing between the two chassis
because they're sitting at different
voltages but it means nothing because it
is not part of the signal communication
the signal communication
is between the two wires uh
there are the they're transmitting
between a receiver and transmitter
and therefore it is not impacted by this
ground noise the
hum and buzz can continue and there's no
problem there
okay so just to bring give you some
personal insight i measure tons of tons
of audio electronics
about 90 of the time when i measure
something with an rca connection
i see contributions from from maine so i
see
60 hertz in us that we have if we're if
i were measuring in
in europe how we get you know 50 hertz
and i'd see it you know also harmonics
of it 60 i may get to see at 120 180 and
and so forth and but whenever i measure
differentially
sorry with balance 99.9
of the time there's zero contributions
so you have to assume that
every piece of equipment you have
currently has ground loops in it
and what we call this ground loop
because remember it's a circuit
and that there's ground noise why do you
not hear at 99
of the time is because uh threshold of
hearing is quite high
and this noise level is below threshold
of hearing so we don't hear it
i can measure with my instrumentation
but you don't hear it
um so what has been a broken
architecture has survived all this time
because
we basically don't hear it if we heard
it you know we would never tolerate it
we would have gone to this kind of
differential system again balances
so that was the presentation so bottom
line
the safety ground in your equipment
is for safety do not do not do not
go put in another grounding system or go
spend
money on grounding doodads and wires
that go to grounding buses
there are people who sell you a box with
dirt in it with a probe in it
thinking that as a ground just like
you're outside you know if i just put a
metal
inside some dirt and sell you as a box
that's grounding things
yes you can plug that into your uh
system
people that usually has one wire
connection that's a
you know the telltale sign is
something's wrong and
people connect that to the chassis of
their audio code and immediately notice
improvement
the improvements in your head you
want you're paying more attention you're
drilling more into the audio
and all of a sudden you heard more
detail none of that has
anything to do with that device as i
always say my videos have someone
connected disconnected
see if you can tell when they've done
that i guarantee you you will fail
i have them go behind the equipment and
not tell you whether you've connected or
not
and you guess whether you know if it's
so obvious that the veil is removed and
the noise floors are improved
then you should be able to tell none of
us are watching by the way so it
shouldn't be stressful
just have somebody else do the plug and
unplug in do it
you know eight or ten times if you get
it right every time i guarantee you you
will not
notice a difference and please don't do
things there's
you know safety hazards like you know
secondary grounds and so forth
okay hopefully this uh made sense i
thought it's an important topic
to cover if you have questions or
concerns uh
raise them in audio science review
thread
uh would probably be easier than trying
to answer them in in
youtube with just you know a few words
here and there
but it's an important concept from
safety point of view and
from fidelity point of view okay see you
in a future
video bye bye